good morning John hope you're feeling
better you missed a video for the first
time in a long time because you're very
sick and I cannot hold it against but to
make you feel better I'm going to talk
about everybody's favorite topic which
is the complexity of the US tax code so
fun it's not gonna happen it's not it's
complicated and it's too complicated I
think everybody agrees that it's too
complicated just nobody agrees on how is
the best way to simplify this so instead
of talking about that let's talk about
why it's complicated in the first place
because you think maybe we can just make
this really simple to start all over
again how would you do well the simplest
way to do that would be a head tax a
head tax would be taxing every single
person the exact cinema so you enter the
world and your fee for existing in the
u.s. is like twelve thousand dollars a
year if everybody paid twelve thousand
dollars a year we would pay the entire
federal budget and it would be good this
works really well for families like mine
I could afford to pay twelve thousand
dollars a year for all the people in my
family how's that work as well for
people who don't make any money like
retirees or disabled people also for all
the people that that would be like all
their money that they made that would be
about work all year you make like eight
thousand dollars then what happens the
government just comes in.they up they
just take you take you to tax jail
so ahead ducks that's not gonna work so
instead let's tax people's income if you
don't make any money you don't pay
anything if you make a lot of money you
pay a bunch for a flat tax to work on
individual human income you got to pay
get ready for it a 50% flat tax a little
bit more than that actually every single
person has to send half the money that
they make to the government and this
sounds wrong right because nobody pays
50% taxes well it turns out we're
missing something because when I was
talking about taxing the amount of money
that people make we gotta examine the
definition of money and of people and of
make all those words because getting
money is just one way to receive value
and if we only text money then everybody
would get paid and like diamonds or gold
or something so we have to tax value so
if I give you a car in exchange for
doing work for me that's still income
and we still tax that the US tax code
doesn't actually tax money it taxes
value this is really important when part
of somebody's payment might be stock in
a company now we gotta examine what is a
person because it turns out a lot of the
money in the US isn't made by
flesh-and-blood human things it's made
by these non-meat people called
corporations
corporate tack currently most
corporations in the US are taxed just as
if they were people so I own business if
it's the end of the year one of my
businesses has more money in its bank
account than it had at the beginning of
the year that difference is taxed as if
it is my money because the day I control
that corporation I control the money and
so I pay the exact same taxes on it that
I would if it was just my money that's
how it works right now that's not how
the Republicans and Congress want it to
work they want people like me if I have
money that's getting made by my
corporation to pay like way less tax on
that I don't know why cuz it's still
income to me but I guess I don't I let
go that's not what we're here for that's
not what we're doing we're not analyzing
the tax thing we're just talking about
why it's complaining and now we have to
talk about the definition of make if you
just tax people's ordinary income you're
not catching a huge chunk of what
happens there's another way to make
money and a lot of people make money
this way and that's when you buy
something and then it becomes worth more
and then you sell it and you make money
this is called capital gains and it
happens mostly with real estate and with
stocks in but the stock market so
instead of talking about taxing the
amount of money people make we're
actually talking about more like the
like the
you receive by entities which make make
you not surprised to see how there's the
black CD is two really good common-sense
reasons not to tax people who don't make
very much money one they tend to spend
almost all of their income anyway they
save very little and if they have less
money they are more likely to end up
being supported by Social Services which
costs the government money and to
because they don't make very much money
taxing them actually doesn't contribute
that much to the budget like you could
increase their tax bill an amount that
would be extremely impactful to them but
it would not be impactful to the budget
so you wanted tax the reason people less
make a bunch of tax wrapping saving
welcome plan tax people who make a bunch
of money more one because we can afford
it and two because you make way more
money when you raise their percentage
because they have so much more income
now the second or last reason why the
tax code is so complicated I'm not even
gonna sing it just because the
government wants to encourage certain
behaviors in people it gives people tax
credits for saving money for retirement
for going to school for saving money for
health care that's you write off parts
of your mortgage because they want to
encourage homeownership that kind of
thing the government also has provisions
for just things that like they're trying
to be more fair for example right now if
you go to graduate school you might make
like ten thousand dollars a year in
actual money but you get tuition
deferment so you don't have to pay your
tuition but that is value being
delivered so technically that value of
your deferred tuition is income because
you've got that value remember we've
talked about value not money if you got
like thirty five thousand dollars of
income from your tuition deferment but
you don't have any actual income that's
a huge burden for graduate students so
that is not counted as income as part of
the tax code at least at the moment but
again we're not talking about what
they're planning on doing in Congress
right now that's not this discussion
finally the last reason why taxes are so
complicated
rich douchebags avoiding their taxes so
we've got to make up lots of rules to
keep them paying their taxes it's gonna
come across something really annoying in
Mike like business tax stuff I'm like
why is this rule even here and then I
realize it's because somebody was using
some underhanded little thing to avoid
paying their taxes and the government
had to create a new rule thanks so much
I'm so glad you didn't have to pay those
ten thousand dollars so that now
everybody in the world has to deal with
this new rule taxes are complicated
I don't like it nobody likes that
everyone would like there to be a
simpler system I do worry when people
are talking about simplifying it because
every change to the US tax code has real
impacts on real people and ultimately if
you want one reason why it's so
complicated
that's it that's the reason John I'll
see you on Tuesday
[Music]